what part of the active conflict makes
you think things will stop has Joe Biden
come out and said I want to be a good
president to everyone in this country
and knowing that there are 80 million
Americans who are skeptical and hesitant
to vaccines I want to have a
conversation with you and work with you
that's why I'm going to be announcing
you know a new plan to work with
Republican leaders and have discussions
over protecting civil liberties no he
doesn't do that he says he what did he
say we've been patient but our patience
is wearing thin power who's he talking
about it's right he could I mentioned
this before when he came out when Texas
and Florida announced that they were
shutting they're like we're not going to
do these shutdowns we're not going to
have these mandates he came out and said
we may need more restrictions we may
need more mask mandates and that was an
important Point earlier this year I said
who is he talking to he wasn't talking
to Texas he wasn't talking to South
Dakota South Dakota never shut down he
wasn't talking to Florida no he was
talking only to Blue States Joe Biden is
the president who comes out on TV and
says us and we against you you know he
just he just pulled off the biggest in
my opinion military blunder in American
history he he surrendered to the Taliban
after a 20-year war that we had control
we were in control of China I think more
than anybody else devastated not only
the way we look in the world who would
trust us to Ally with us if we're going
to walk away and leave them to die
afterwards if we're looking at who
benefits the most from everything that
Biden's doing I don't have to say
probably China's benefit in the most so
he's Saving Face this is him coming out
hard out of the closet to be angry to
take the immediately I'm like what is he
talking about anything other than
Afghanistan for right now he wants to
focus on how cool he how strong he is
this is totally total power play another
thing I agree this policy doesn't fly
it's going to get sued into Oblivion
he'll probably try and bypass Supreme
Court anyway but boy boy did it change
the conversation yeah we're talking
about this instead of Afghanistan now
yeah another thing is like I I wonder
because I know you were saying that they
kind of want the states to split in a
way where like Florida is its own state
I I wonder how that's going to go
because I know in New York City I'll
just use this as a smaller scale example
my hometown Staten Island
it's technically part of New York City
it pays New York City taxes pays New
York state taxes but everyone in Staten
Island for the most part it's the only
Republican Borough out of the entirety
of New York City it's not even it's not
anything like anything else in New York
City geographically and the people
but they refused to let Staten Island
secede from New York City they just
refuse I believe it's because they don't
want
a part of New York that's not adherent
to the New York City tax code
and just have everybody from New York
City just living over there in Staten
Island because what would happen is tons
of businesses will just okay we're just
gonna go right over the bridge we're
gonna we're gonna just move right over
the bridge in Manhattan would just lose
tons of business
New York City tax I think is like 3.5
3.5 percent just and there's no reason
for Staten Island to be paying that
because we're nothing like the rest of
the city it's just a completely
different world it might as well just be
New Jersey at that point yeah and I feel
like that's going to be the same exact
thing when it comes to Florida and Texas
if they want to secede if Florida and
Texas ever did get out of there they're
either gonna have to one try to destroy
the economy of that of those States as
much as possible so this way no one
would ever want to live there or they
would have to force them to stay because
they don't want it to become a beacon of
Freedom where it's zero percent taxes
every business just come here you've got
no federal government breathing down
your neck you want to have your trillion
dollar business here you want to have
your small business here yeah just come
here No One's Gonna bother you just come
here and do whatever you want and check
it out right now there's a lot going on
with these vaccine mandates Truckers
if the truckers of the United States
right now said I'm good
strike whole country shuts down
everything yeah everything shuts down
they have all the power people don't
realize when you when you zoom out on
America you look at America on the
satellite map you look at it in real
time I'm not saying you actually have
access to do that but let's say you
could you know what you see on the roads
you see on all the highways they look
like veins and you know what those
trucks are those are the red blood cells
carrying the oxygen to all of the major
centers to make sure that people can
survive how does it work with Amazon do
they own their own truck drivers oh dude
when you order so in rural areas when
you order from Amazon it comes it gets
delivered to a post office and then it
either come or actually we when we order
on Amazon
we get UPS FedEx and post and postal
deliveries for Amazon stuff when in in
the cities there's an Amazon warehouse
and they hire their own drivers and the
person will show up put it in their car
drive it to you not here we get that
sometimes but typically it has to be
delivered through a it's still going to
go from the production Center in the
warehouse to these distribution centers
either way so it's got to come from a
big truck then their little drivers can
handle it well here's here's the
important point
let's say you live in Texas no vaccine
mandates
they're like we got we got a shipment
it's going out to New York can't do it
yeah because if I go there I'm not going
to be able to eat any food or go to
restaurants I'm not going to do it yeah
I'm not going to be able to go into the
gas station sorry actually not even
going to be able to go into the the the
the warehouse to drop it off
now there may be some exceptions like oh
you're just dropping something off fine
you're getting takeout New York says
it's fine there's probably reasons why
they did this but how many of these
truck drivers are gonna be like and not
worth the risk I'm not going to drive
all that way for this job and then find
out that I can't even interact the other
way is different New York will be able
to go to Texas vaccinated New York truck
drivers will have no problem going to
Texas so it's all going to start flowing
towards these red thing is these cities
are the ones that really need these
imported supplies and goods too
yeah I I think
um you know I don't know exactly how
this plays out
you know I've said for a long time Civil
War and we were just talking about that
but I do think based on the Hugo of data
about it's 37.2 percent of people want
their region to break apart from the
United States or I'm sorry yeah yeah
each different uh region has a different
population size but overall in the
United States there's a 37.2 percent of
people want their region to break apart
I look at that and I'm like maybe it's
just a balkanization maybe that's not
even the right word for it because you
know you talk about like the Balkan Wars
and stuff and you know the balkanization
that happened maybe what we're going to
see is a little bit different and it's
more going to be just a disillusion of
the Union yeah decentralization of the
Union the states become the states and
take care of their own business and
that's it I think we've been in maybe
not a civil war but with first of all
the Federal Reserve really those guys
really want to take control of the
American economy which they kind of did
then the Soviets we had the Communist
American conflicts or then we had the
Chinese which we still have so it's like
we've been in this conflict for for 100
years and it's it's evolved and morphed
into a different shape where it's like
me and you and you we all these
different opinions now your neighbors
aren't the people that you relate to
them and so there's all this
psychological conflict that's being sewn
and I hate seeing Americans versus
Americans on this I don't think that's
the pro what it is we got divided over
the last 18 years really really sadly
unnecessarily it's it's more than just
an American problem it's a global
problem and I think we really need to be
unified closer and closer to what's
happening in Australia that's where it
works
I got to disagree with you you you you
constantly you know want to like you
hold this belief of like we shouldn't be
divided people should come together but
I think you missed the boat on that one
a long time ago I can't stop though I
can't stop myself I get it but look two
different these are things I was talking
about in 2016. yeah I was like 20 hey
2007. hey guys we sh we shouldn't be
hyperpolarizing like this we can't just
be pointing the fingers 2018 I'm like yo
this fighting's got to stop people I
actually said people should stop showing
up to these things to just simmer down I
understand people want to go out and
protest they have a right to do it but
all it's going to do is create a tit for
a tattoo why don't people just chill out
right now now we're at the point there
is no turning back you got people like
Hassan [ __ ] one of the biggest if not
the biggest independent political
commentator cheering for Nationwide rule
by decree cheering for it mocking those
as as you have someone uh Biden in
office violating like overtly violating
the Constitution the law over overruling
legislation Supreme Court on multiple
occasions and he's cheering for it while
at the same time you have some of these
same people saying of the abortion law
in Texas is wrong the government you
know my body my choice oh but this is
contagious we shouldn't allow it we
shouldn't allow the virus to kill people
but we should be allowed to abort babies
but see there's no there's no logical
consistency other than give me the power
to enact the things I want there is no
reconciling that in when these people by
like 54 believe the economy is doing
good right now there's I'm sorry man
they come out and they claim that every
Trump supporter is ingesting horse pace
which is just not true it's a small they
did the same thing with the Trump and
the bleach situation right right it's a
it's it first of all Trump said
something dumb and they act like people
actually believe that stuff but I'll
tell you this the reality independent
voters and Republican voters are not
running around ingesting horse Pace it's
just not happening some some people are
and it's stupid thing journey is the guy
that they're making making fun of Joe
Rogan ended up getting better in like
three days but he went to a doctor and
the doctor gave him a prescription he
got monoclonal antibodies which is an
FDA authorized treatment and that's
probably what did it yeah but here's the
point we we can say definitively yeah we
know there are dumb people going to
Tractor Supply you go to Tractor Supply
this horse space missing because people
bought it but they only had like 30
boxes anyway so there's not tens of
millions of crackpots you look at the
Republicans right now the Republicans in
the polls Mo a large portion do not like
the Republican party because they're
paying attention independent voters
think the economy is bad don't like the
Republicans or the Democrats
the metric Democrats believe in the
economy is good is proof these people
live in Wally World evidence evidence
it's not proof but it's there's only
like 3 000 people though that that I
think that study it was only like three
times uh that showed the Democrats
thought the economy was good no it's
like a hundred thousand is it I thought
that was a different study no no it's
like 100 there's still only maybe they
think it's good because they're getting
their checks in the mail right no it's
because Joe might have got elected and
also there's a spike in people believe
the economy was gonna get a hundred
thousand morons in any political here's
the other thing I guess when it comes to
the Ubi and all these checks that
everyone's been getting
I guess Andrew Yang in the whole I guess
Ubi socialist crowd are saying we need
this money we need this money it will be
productive it'll go to good it'll help
us do this help us do that and what
happens when the a lot of these people
get their money Louis Vuitton stock
Skyrocket you know because they're going
to be buying Gucci bags Louis purses
whatever they're doing I live in Vegas
now and I've been flying back and forth
and what I noticed is probably 75
percent of the flights have been
extremely ghetto
extremely Rowdy no flight etiquette I
mean have you seen these videos people
fighting and boxing on planes they're
coming on the planes and they got boom
boxes and they're blasting music they're
cursing at the flight attendants they're
yelling at the pilots oh we're gonna
have a 10 minute delay Landing a little
bit busy today you're lying to us you're
effing lion to us get us off freaking
out this is like 75 of the fights I've
been going on lately in and out of Vegas
have been like that also I talked to a
lot of people on The Strip a lot of
security they said at the time when I
was talking to them they said crime has
been going up on the strip and I asked
why I came to the conclusion I think
this might be true that because the
Airlines and uh the casinos they're all
giving these deals to get people back
into the City and people are all having
these checks come in the mail that never
earned it and they just want to go blow
it and they're getting you know less
desirable people coming into town
starting problems starting crime I even
when I was in the casino uh not too long
ago I had I think three people try to
start a fight with me one person tried
to start a fight with me because I asked
if I liked Alex Jones and they tried to
start a fight with me they asked you
yeah they asked me because I was having
a political conversation with my
friend's mom and they turned around
they're like you like Alex Jones I'm
like I think he's cool he's definitely
entertaining well you're uh and he just
called me you know one of these words
that I can't say no not not he
definitely oh he called you a slur yeah
and that's what YouTube bans us for yeah
I was like dude just go just go away
from me and then like literally I go to
another table and someone like yells Joe
because the guy next to me his name was
Joe he wasn't with me and I like glance
back and I looked back he's like and I
wasn't F in talking to you and he starts
to try to size me up I'm like bro get
out of here like what are you doing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time